では よろしくお願いします
これからダンマパダの勉強を始まります
今日の偈文は六十三番目
まず読み上げます Yo
bālo maññati bālaṃ paṇḍito vāpi tena so. Bālo ca paṇḍita māni sabbe bālo’ti
uccati. Yo bālo maññati bālaṃ paṇḍito vāpi tena so. Bāl
o ca paṇḍita māni sabbe
bālo’ti uccati ti.これ
かなりお釈迦様の有名な言葉になっていまして
自分の国でお釈迦様が涅槃に入られて二千五百年という節目の祭りを最大にやっていて
大きな道路で ものすごい立て
看板じゃなくて旗をね
ずっともう飾ってあって
各旗にブッダの言葉がいろいろ書いてます
シンハラ語で その中でこれも一つありまして
なんかすごいそれ読みながら楽しくなりましたけどね
その時感じたのは お釈迦様っていうのはいかにすごいことを言っているのかということで
人類に対してものすごい大事なことをおっしゃっていると
なかなか我々はもういかに大事かということを感じないのは残念だと
なぜならば 聖書にも立派な言葉がありますけど
やっぱりある宗教の言葉というね
色 匂いというのは出てくるんですよ
ブッダの言葉には その宗教の匂いも色もないんです
全ての人類にすごい言葉だなと思えるような言葉なんですよ
わざとそういう言葉を選んで飾りに使ってあった可能性もありますけどもね
この偈っていうのはものすごい有名な偈で
またわかりやすくてね
説法にもそんなに苦しくはないと思います
それから意味を申し上げます Yo
bālo maññati bālaṃ Yo bāloっていうのは Yo
っていうのは誰か 誰かということで
関係代名詞でbāloっていうのは愚か者
無知な人ということで
知恵のない人が maññati
bālaṃ maññatiっていうのは気になる
気にする 思う 気づく 考えるという言葉なんですね
大体別な経典になってくると maññati
っていう言葉は妄想するという単語に使いますよ
だから妄想するといっても
考えることも知ることも同じことだからね
結局はね この場合はよくわかっているという意味になるんですね
気になっている 無知な人
愚か者は気になっている
何でしょうかと bālaṃ
自分の自分の愚かさを
ちょっとこれ気になっている
自分の愚かさを 困ったな
私は頭が悪いと いわゆる気づいている
自分がそれほど頭がいい人間でないということをよく知っている paṇḍito
vāpi tena so. tena so.だったらその人は賢者だよと
その人は賢者 賢者というか
知恵のある人や頭いいんだと
それで十分だとということなんです
もっと俗っぽく言えばね
無知な人は無知に気づけば
無知な人は自分が無知であることを知っているならば賢者になると
[音楽]二行目 バーローチャ・パンディタマーニ
バーロー 無知な人 愚か者
なのにパンディタマーニ
私って結構もののこと知ってるんだよと
頭がいいんだよと いう思いでいるならば
自分が頭いいと思っているならば
サヴェーバーローティウッチャティ
サヴェー 彼こそが愚か者だ
もっと省略すれば 頭が悪いと知ってるんだったらもう心配することはないんです
もう頭良くなります 頭が悪いと気づいてないならば
もうどうしようもないということになるんですね
もう勘違いして頭がいいと
勘違いしているならば
もうどうしようもないんだと
結局はこれってお釈迦様はものすごい一般的に言っているようなんですけど
すごくどうしてもお釈迦様はすごい難しい高いレベルの真理を語るんですよ
こちらで結局は愚か者しか出てこないんですよ
愚か者は二種類 一つは自分の愚かさに気づいている
もう一つは気づいてない
それだけ 結局はブッダの立場から見れば
悟り開いてない人々はみんな無知愚か者なんです
だから愚か者二種類にしたんです
だから人間が所詮無知であることはもう当然当たり前のことで
これにはごちゃごちゃうんうんと言う必要はないんです
しかし その中で自分の愚かさに気づいているかいないかということは
ものすごい大事なポイントですと
気づいているならば これ気になっているならば
もうそれで智慧のある人になるんだよと
ということなんですね
そこで我々生きているこの世の中で
私たちはいつでも何に挑戦しているかというと
このあれ知ってる これ知ってるというところ
知ってるものばっかり見せびらかすためにすごく挑戦しているんですね
いろいろ学位を厚く収集したりするしね
で いろいろ免許何々免許何々免許持ってるとかね
なんとか何段何段とかね
そういう風に自分の肩書を厚めに
かなり踏ん張ってる人々はいるんですよ
その中 そういう人々も私はそれなりには知ってますけど
すごく頭悪いっていうことはものすごく痛感したことがあるんですね
頭が 悪い癖に何とか何とか何とかと
もう学歴 肩書きだけは
今思い出すと ある人がいて
自分の国の人なんですけど
あの まあまとめない試験っていうことは
何一つも合格したことがないと思いますけどね
一応大学に入っていて
私の先輩なんですけど
頭がどれほどいいというと
彼が卒業試験の彼の卒業試験の採点したのは私なんです
ということは その時私は大学の教師でいるってことなんです
大学では先輩なんですけど
学生としては私より先に入りましたけどね
で 先に入って 何かあの
試験でね もうなんかカンニングやっちゃったみたいですね
これは向こうは厳しい
その場で×ということで
まあ年ストップさせて
年 三年とか その程度によってストップさせるんです
もう国のどんな試験も受けることできません
その間にはその場でもう罰決めるんです
もうそれに反対して裁判にかけることは可能ですけど
かけても意味がないんです
なぜならば 試験場の監督する人の証言はもう変えられない証言だから
その人々も同じ大学の先生たちなんですけど
きちっと証拠集めて判子押して
本人のサインもらって
認めてくださいと これでもう帰ってくださいと
その場で返されるんです
時々返すことをしないで
とにかく続けて書いてくださいという場合もあります
しかし どんな結果になるかわからないんだと
それで全部試験終わりまで受けても
向こうで決めたらもう取り消しと言ったら
取り消しでまた何年 何年間停止
そういう羽目になっちゃって
私はもう教えることになったから
もうやっぱりその時でもね
名前はわかりません 本当は名前わからないはずなんですけど
答案を読む場合はね 番号だからね
でもわかりますね これあの人やと
それ見て私は初めてびっくりしたんですよ
こんなに頭の悪い奴らが世の中でいるのかと
なぜならば 社会では結構人気というか
有名というか もうもうその人の家に壁がないんです
あらゆる証明書もかけてあって
壁という壁はないんです
私にもこの子供とかよく言われたから
あの人っていうのはね
すごい人ですよとかね
いっぱい色々な certificate を持ってるんだよとか
そうですかと それを聞いて
それからもうちゃんと中身を私が見たんだから
後でね これはもう中学生年生の知識もろくにないんではないかという
でもなんとか取れるところでは certificate という証明書ってなんとか取る
それで名刺書く場合はもうもうハガキ 1枚ぐらい必要になる
それで一般人がそれを知らんだからね
すごい人やとと思っちゃうんですね
だからそのケースなし出した方は人間っていうのは私はこれも知ってる
あれも知ってる あれも知ってると言いたくて言いたくてたまらんですね
いわゆる自分の裏笠に気付くことじゃなくて
逆をやろうとしているんです
実際 まあ私はもう一応大学の世界で
教授たちの間で大人になったもんだから
もう小さい時 もうそれな若い時からね
まあ私は知っている人々はもう結構みんな知識人たちでね
で こうすごいもう怖いほど知識人もいるし
能力ある やっぱり喋っていると
私はあれ知ってる これ知ってるって話は全然出てこないんです
めちゃくちゃいろんなことをしゃべりながら
やっぱりこれはね 勉強しなきゃあかんねとかね
ここら辺知らないんだからね
困ったねとかね 時々自分たちがもう年でなかなか勉強そこら辺間に合わないわよ
あんたでもやってくださいよ
もうもう私たちはね 時間的に間に合わないんだからとかね
これこれ知らなきゃダメでしょうとかね
もうすごくまたすごい立派な教授がいて
あの その教授はもう私のところにもうニコニコと来て
いきなりスマナサーラさん
あんたソグディアン勉強してソグディアン勉強した方がいいんじゃないの？と言うんですね
ソグディアンというのは中アジアに昔あった言語なんですよ
トルファンとかね そこら辺で
なんで？だっていろいろ経典のテキストとか発掘するって出ますよと
やっぱりあれはね もう元々読んでね
研究できなかったらもう仏教研究はやっぱりもうダメでしょうね
新しい発掘するものを付け加えなきゃとか
やっぱり知らないことに興味あるんですよ
でも本人にとってみたら
もう大教授でもそろそろ退職するし
今さらソグディアン だから私も思い出しちゃって
すぐ自分にかけて あんたね
ソグディアン勉強しなさいと
それでもつぐらいソグディアンとコータンと何とか何とか勉強しますと
で 結局私たちにもそういう先生たちのあの影の下でいるんだから
俺が知ってるっていう気分が出てこないんですよ
ああ 知らないな 困ったなとかね
あれも知らない まあ困ったなとかね
だからいつでも知らないものばっかり
この世の中でという気分でいるんですね
だからそれでなんとなく振り返ってみると
それなりにいくつかのものは知ってるんだけど
知らないものはそれでも多いということで
どうしようもないと これで生徒たちを教える時でも
やっぱり俺が知ってるぞという態度取ると
もう明らかにダメっていうことがわかるんですね
全くもって育てられないと
だからすごくそれは今も今もありますよ
拒絶反応みたいに もうすぐ拒絶反応起こるんですよ
私はね まあもう半年間も法華経を勉強しましたけどってやってくると
口でもう拒絶反応出てるんです
もう長い間の癖だからね
しょうがないんですよ
言い方によりますけどね
法華経はもう半年間勉強しましたからと言っちゃうと
はい どうぞ あちら玄関ですと
逆に言えば もう半年ももう 3年間も法華経と戦ってるんだけど
私は って言っちゃうと
こいつは戦ってるんだからね
助けてあげなくちゃと
という気持ちになるんですよ
だから知ってるぞという側面を出しちゃうと
もうやっぱりもう だから皆様の質問に対してでも
私は微妙に態度変わる
時々きびしく言ったりしたりして
それは相手が私はここまで知ってるんだからねという態度になってくると
ビシッとそれを壊すんです
たくさん知ってるのに知らない方が多いでしょうというと
その人はその位置できちっと置いておいて
そこから進んでくださいと勧めるようにはしてあげる
もうだからお釈迦様は困ったなと
お釈迦様は先生だからね
もうものすごい本格的な
もう人類のね 生命の本物の先生ですから
サッターデヴァマヌッサなんだからね
人間神々の先生だからね
師匠だから やっぱりずっとそれで師匠として
先生として生徒たちを教える場合はということで
教育的な目で見るんですよ
だから教育学的に見ても
どんな生徒を成長育てるか
どんな生徒を育てられないかというと
この微妙なところなんですね
しかし それが先生にはどうすることもできないんですよ
あんたは愚か者だと認めなさいという
できるわけないでしょうに
先生の仕事 お前頭がいいねえということでしょ
頑張ればできる 頭がいいんだからとか
それが先生の仕事であって
どうにもならん それは
我々教える側もとんでもない馬鹿というのを本当にできる人なんですよ
すごくできて もうやりすぎになっちゃう
心配だから あまりやりすぎになっちゃって失敗しちゃうと
本人がそれでもう落ち込んじゃってね
どうなるかわからないんだから心配で
お前本当にバカだからとか何とか言ってちょっと捨てるんですけど
それはバカって意味じゃないんです
それは生徒たちもそれよく理解する
何のこともないこと言ってるんだと
でも頭の本当に悪い人に向かって
あんた頭が悪いって言えないでしょうに
大丈夫よ 頑張ればちょこちょことことことやればもう何のことないよと励まさなければいけないしね
だから自分のことに気づくっていうことは
あくまでも本人の 問題なんですね
だからそれで人が私って結構頭いいなという高慢でいる場合は悲しいんですよ
お釈迦様はすごく悲しい
悲しいではなくて ものすごくその憐れみの気持ちになったと思いますよ
なんでこの人はこんな態度を取るのかと
あの傲慢さえ捨てれば悟り開けるのにとかね
こんなにももう人類の最高な先生の前でね
たった二 三分で導くことできる能力を持ってる人の前でね
あの微妙な態度をとっちゃうと
すべてアウトになっちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様にしてみれば
かなりもう気になってたまらなかった考え方だと思いますよ
ですから ブッダの場合は
あなたは何を教える人と質問しちゃうと逆にやられるだけ
一度も答えたことはないんです
あんた何を教える人ってすごい態度でかいでしょ
質問する人は 俺が全部知っていてね
あんたの教えは何？という態度でしょ
いきなりね あんた方にはね
理解できんと あるいは逆にものすごくもう相手の気持ちもものすごく侮辱というか
侮辱と侮辱というより酷いんだからね
もう徹底的にもう精神的にももう落ちるような答え出すんです
もう喋れなくなっちゃうんです
で なんでそんなに厳しく
もう精神的に自信っていうのは全てなくなって
もうアホにバカになるまで厳しい言葉を言うのかという
それでもいいんだと この人の高慢なく壊れるならば
それでもその人たちにはいいことで
ブッダってもう二度と顔を合わせなくても
世の中ででもそれから謙虚でいられますからね
それでちょこちょこちょこちょこで勉強になるんだから
それからその人を覚えるでしょ
人にはいきなり攻撃するもんじゃないんだと
人間の能力は顔と違いますよと
肩書きと違いますよとわかるでしょうに
時々また一箇所ぐらい思い出しましたけど
それなりの行者たちがね
の他宗教のね そこにお釈迦様がいたところで
みんな偉そうに釈尊はね
どんな教えを教えるんでしょうかと聞くんで
その場合はなんとなく同じ質問なんですけど
微妙に態度が違う その人々の場合は
その場合は我々も一生懸命なんとか宗教信仰をして頑張ってはいるんですけど
お釈迦様はどういうものでしょうかというね
その時お釈迦様が言うんです
そういうふうに質問しないでくださいと
こういうふうな質問をしてくださいと
我々の教えはこういうものである
それについてお釈迦様は何言うんでしょうかと
お釈迦様では如来の答えは何でしょうかと
言うと 本人たちがすごく喜んで
あ 我々のことを聞いてるんだからこれ言ってやるぞと
自分たちずっと勉強しているものだからね
そうなると胸を張って喋れますよ
その瞬間には お釈迦様が偉大なる先生として相手に自信をつけてあげるんです
堂々と語りなさいよと
堂々と語りなさいと言っても
人の教えを語れませんでしょ
だから自分たちがずっと学んでいるものを堂々と語りなさいよと
その語ったところの中で
いろいろ間違っているところをお釈迦様見せてあげて
正しいところを見せてあげて
完成するのはこういうふうに完成しますよと教えてくれる
あと 本人たちが気付かずきちんと道を知っているんです
自分を非難されたこともないし
批判されたこともないし
あなた方の宗教は間違っているよと言われたこともないし
君たちも頑張っているんだから
このままこのままで こういうふうに
こういうふうに こういうふうに
こういうふうにいてください
それで完成しますよということだから
すごく親切に導いちゃうんです
だからそういうところというのは
ものすごい微妙に お釈迦様のやり方っていうのはものすごく微妙に複雑なんです
だから一言葉一言葉無駄がなくて
お釈迦様怒鳴ったらそれ無駄じゃないんです
褒めたらそれは無駄じゃないんです
何一つ無駄がないということは
一つのブッダたる特色なんです
だからお釈迦様はニコッと笑っても
アーナンダ尊者 なんで笑った？何か無駄ではないと
そちらにも何かあるんだと
なんとなく笑ったとはありえないんです
だからどんな乱暴な言うこと聞かない出家比丘たちでも
悪いことしたらお釈迦様が一応追放したりしますけどね
あなた方は今から追放と言ったらみんな反論はしません
言われたらすぐ衣を畳んで別のお寺に行く
無駄がないんだからね
お釈迦様が追放したら
それこそ我々にとっての幸福な道であると
素直に出ていけばいいと
だからもう一生懸命瞑想修行する人々
時々いてね お釈迦様 どこかちょっと二人で遊びましょう
どこか行きましょうとかね
瞑想に邪魔して連れて行ったりする
ひと言 ない これが自分にとっては最高な幸福な道である
はい わかりましたと 一緒に散歩をする
その時なんとかなんとこ様が教えますからね
それで悟りを開けるんです
ある日はお坊さんたちが何かすごい真夜中ちょこっと祈りしていて
どなったこと 何者かと思ってるんですかと
祈りしながら 一切は燃えているというのは
お前らよく祈りする暇があるもんだなと
ものすごい厳しい ということは
出家をする人々にとってはもう一日も 1分 5分も寝られないことになるでしょうに
それはそのグループに行ったんであって
もう一つの他のところに行ってね
なんで夜寝ないのかと
また下戸に呼んです またお釈迦様の親戚になる人がね
というか まあ元叔父なんですけどね
お釈迦様はまあ大体側近とそばになんとかなんとかね
もう自分は身近にいろんなことを頼む場合は
同じ祖父祖母の親戚にしか頼まないということもありますけどね
まあ義理の兄弟でね それでまあ一緒に托鉢出て
まあ蜂とか上の重い子供とか
その人に渡って持ってきてくださいとお釈迦様は歩いてて
まあ結局兄弟でもあるんだからね
それでこのお坊さんがね
すごい立派な公園庭を見てね
なんで落ち着いてる雰囲気かなとかね
ここでこんな風な修行に入ればいいんじゃないかと
そしたらお釈迦様に お釈迦様
私はね この立派なところ
こちらで今からもう瞑想して悟り目指してこれから修行に入る
だから子供とこの鉢を
持って 持って お釈迦様はウータラに戻ってください
私は泊まりますと ここから修行と言ったら
お釈迦様ね えーとね 私は一人ですからね
一緒に来て それやめて瞑想やめて
なんだろう すごい俗っぽくな考え方でしょ
ちゃんと出て行って泊まって
私は一人でしょうに お釈迦様寂しいような感じで
私は一人ぼっちでテーラワーダ行かなくてはいけないし
一緒に行きましょうと
ただ何をおっしゃるんですかと
1分たりとも怠ける 衰
なんていうか 何て言ったっけ？怠ることなく修行するべきではないかと
私は修行に入りますよ
そう言ったって私は一人ぼっちだから一緒に来いよと
それでも聞かない  3回も
お釈迦様ことわって瞑想しないで一緒に行きましょうと聞かなかったんです
これは兄弟のわがままやと思いますよ
だけ他の人ならそんなことは断りませんだからね
そこでお釈迦様はもう鉢と
お釈迦様はそれでも受け取らない
鉢を 全くじゃあ持ってくださいと手を出さない
そこまでお釈迦様反対するんですよ
瞑想に だから結局言ってるのは今やめなさいって意味なんですよ
だからもうどうそう鉢をと出しているのに
お釈迦様は手を出さない
出さないんだから その人は地面の上に置いておいて
まあどうそうと帰っちゃったんで
あの森の中 公園の中に入ったんです
お釈迦様もしょうがないんだから
鉢を持ってもうウータラに戻りましたけどね
あの人はすぐ帰りました
1時間  2時間は瞑想できなかった
公園に入った途端 むちゃくちゃ自分の俗世間でやったことを思い出してしまって
もう遊んだことやら いろんなお妃たちと遊んだり
酒飲んだことやら もう贅沢にものすごく頭に出てきて
体中欲の波動がもう溢れかえって
本人でもいてもたってもいられなくなって
あれどうなってるか 自分が病気になったんじゃなくて
自分がもう真剣真面目に信仰を持たせて信仰に持って出家したのに
こんなはずがないんだと
もうどうしようもないと
もういてもたっても やっぱり正直なとこ正直で
このままいたらもう自分が破壊しちゃって
もう減速する羽目になるんだっていうことでね
逃げちゃ走っても走ることはなくて
すぐもうお釈迦様のところにはどうかもうダメですと
助けてくださいと お釈迦様はこうやってこの野郎
ダメと言ったのにとかね
だからそれが先生なんですよ
知ってます だからこの仏教徒の徹底的なもう本当に信仰ある人っていうのは
ブッダに言われたらもう全くもう文句言わない
ブッダがやめろと言ったらやめるんであって
やりなさいと言ったらやるんであって
それぐらいすごいんですよ
まあそういうことだから
まあ先生として教える人としてはね
あの この傲慢の態度取っちゃうと
それだけで心には鍵かけたことになります
中から どうしてもないんです
心っていうのは この他人にフリーアクセスできません
マインドコントロールするとかいろいろあるでしょうね
でも本当に心にはフリーアクセスできません
本人がドアを開けておかないと
ロックを開けておかないと
だからどんな汚れにも大体普通みんなドアの鍵開けてるでしょうね
だから心が汚れるだけであって
だからどちらに心の鍵を開けるかっていうことは自分次第なんです
例えばブッダの話に鍵を開けておくか
ワイドショーに鍵開けてるかっていうことはね
テレビの どちらでも本人は自由です
第3者があんたこのワイドショーばっかり見るんじゃなくて
仏教の本でも読みなさいって言っても意味がないんです
そこで強引に読ませても意味がないんです
寝てますから  1時間読みなさいと
それで本人 1時間も読みますよ
意味がないんです 自分で鍵を開けるか閉めるかということは
ものすごく自由意志なんです
だからマインドコントロールされる人々っていうのは
もう情けない 人間らしくないんですよ
いい加減だから 心のドアっていうのは開けっぱなしで
これまたとんでもない方向へ開けているんだから
それで心のドアを閉める閉めるっていうこともまたすごく危険です
それ自殺行為なんです
自殺してるでしょ 鍵閉めるやつらなんです
生きていられません その肉体はもう潰さないと
だから心を維持管理 エネルギーはやっぱりドアを開けていて
入るデータによって心はもうそれが心に対する燃料なんですね
だからって開けっぱなしだったら二
三瞬間に狂っちゃいます
それでももう何も聞かない
何も知らず知りたくないとかね
なんとかあれも嫌 これも嫌と鍵かけてかけていっちゃうと
もうどんどんどんどん引っ込み思っちゃって
それからどんどんその中でも鍵かけちゃいますからね
それでも自殺で終わっちゃうんです
だから心は開くべきなんですが
それはどのように開くかということ
気をつけなくちゃいけないです
そういうことだから この傲慢というのは心一つの鍵なんですね
例えば怒り 憎しみ 煩悩っていうのは
どれも様々な鍵なんです
例えば すっごく怒っている人には世の中の一部しか見えないでしょ
他のものには鍵かけてるんです
だから怒りの鍵は ある人に対して怒ったということは
その人に対して怒りの鍵であるドアが開けたんです
そのドアから見えるのはその人の欠点だけなんです
全て見えません その人がやった悪いことしか見えません
今までずっといいことをやってきたのに
それはもう見えません
もう それは誰か教えたくて
さらに怒りが膨張するだけ
だから欲も怒りも何でもかんでも鍵なんです
そのその鍵でいろんなドアを開けるんです
それでいろいろそれなりの湾曲したデータが入るんです
だから完全に心のすべてのドアを開けることができる人っていうのを悟った人であって
煩悩がない人なんだ 他の人々にはこれオープンというのは無理です
だから解脱に解脱と自由というね
ヴィムッティという解脱フリーダムという言葉をお釈迦様使ってますから
それは鍵がないというか
鍵全部開けてる まあ心は狭くするのはまあどんな生命にも悟って誰も悟ってないんだからね
やり方 例えば我々は大きな大きなでっかいオープンに北海道みたいな大きなでっかいスペースに行っても
一晩泊まるならば そこら辺ですごい小さい縄張り作るでしょ
何かシート テント その中
ものすごいもう水平線まで見える見えるオープンスペースでは寝ないんです
怖いんですね 別に何もないのに
怖いんだったらテントの中でも怖いことは怖いんだけどね
熊が出て襲うかもしれませんだったら
テントにいたってかなって言って守れるわけないでしょうに
だからあの そういうふうに
この とにかく小さなスペースを作ろうとする
それぞれその人の能力によって
まあワンDKでもいいと
やっぱり二階建ての大きな部屋でなければ
家でなければと それぞれスペース的にも考える人々いるでしょうしね
やっぱり心を我々はね
鍵かけて あらゆる形で狭くしたり大きくしたりっていろいろやってることだけは事実で
どんな生き方を見たってもそれは見える
でもその問題 心理学的なところからすごく複雑ですからね
あまり詳しくは今日喋れませんですけど
すっごい複雑な世界です
悟りっていうのはね もういろいろいっぱい壁があって
壁があって 壁があって
壁の中で中で囲まもうもう小さくリミットしている
鍵かけてかけてる心のこの壁
一つ一つ一つ一つ全部破れちゃうと
最後の塀まで何でも破れちゃうと
自分がどこにいるのかと
そうするとどこにいるかと言えなくなっちゃうでしょ
例えば今こちらでこの土地のね
ちゃんとしたあれ 何て言いますか
あれはね 境界線ってのがありますからね
それで境界線あるんだから
私たちの気持ちはそこら辺に中になってるんですね
すぐそこで あ これ我々のところだと
もしこれ全部ここどこ全て境界線破って破って破って行っちゃうと
住所も何とも言えなくなるでしょ
あんたどこにいる？そこら辺にいるぞってさえも言えなくなっちゃうんです
ま 東西南北ということも境界線なんですよ
じゃあそれもなくなったらどうなるんでしょうか
だから涅槃に入った人は何者かと言えることじゃできません
境界線ないんです 我々は
あなたはよく怒りっぽい人
あんた欲張りやと あんた怠け者
何でも言えますからね
いろいろ持ってますからね
心狭くするもの だから矛盾というのは狭くしつつも
心はどこかどこかで開けているというね
開けてなきゃもうそれで終わり
その命はそこでもう亡くなっちゃうんです
動物でもあまりにも怯えて
もう洞穴の中に隠れちゃっちゃうと
あまりにも鍵かけちゃうと外に出られないでしょ
餌を取るためには 死んじゃうんです
ものすごく恐怖感で脅しちゃうと
動物は穴の中に隠れます
その恐怖感がすごい強烈だったら
そのまんまでもう足も動かなくなっちゃうんです
腰は上がらないんです
それで1日2日3日経って餌を食べてないんだからね
それでも行けなくなっちゃうんです
で 死ぬんです はい で まあ一般的にいるのは
我々はね まあ怒りよくね
そういう鍵を閉めて 慈しみの鍵で鍵でドアを開ければかなり広いんです
それが 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという気分になったら
もう最大限に広い 開いたということになる心は
だから その人に入ってくるエネルギーの量っていうのはね
並大抵じゃないんですよ
ちょこっと誰かに怒って
その衝動で生きてるものとはちょっと違います
家族に依存して 家族は大事だ
家族守らなくちゃ 料理作らなくちゃ
買い物しなくちゃとか
みんな家庭内の鍵開けてるでしょうに
それで元気で生きてますけどね
本人は そのつもりですけど
では生きとし生けるものは？という感じで鍵開けたらどうですか？と
その元気は並大抵のものじゃないんです
とにかく心に必要な燃料
エネルギーはそうやって開けることから現れるんです
悟りっていうことはもっと開けるっていうことは
一切微妙な概念さえも持たないという
概念でも鍵なんです だから概念というのはすべて我々概念で生きてるでしょ
これ天井という概念です
蛍光灯という概念です
それ自体も心を狭くするんです
だから涅槃悟りだけは人間に理解できないんだから
そこら辺で考えないで置いておきなさいと
悟った人はどうなるのかとか
いい加減なことを考えないでくれと
調子に乗るなよと それでも不満だったら
それは究極な幸福です
話は終わりと それで話は終わるんです
本当かというと だって自分がやってます
お釈迦様ね 私を見てください
他の それでもちょっとやってくださいと
もし違うんだったら言ってくれと
それ当時教えるしかないんです
ですから この 時々ね 私は涅槃に入った人はこういう人
こんな感じではないかなと思いますが
いかがでしょうかと聞かれた時もありますけどね
やっぱり 放っておいてくださいっていうことしか言えないんです
そんな何かの鍵で 何かの概念で理解できるものじゃないんですって
だから概念っていうのは心を狭くするっていうことも理解した方がいいんです
例えば自分が蕎麦がすごく好きだという思っちゃうと
それ概念なんですね そんなこと言ったって
人間の食べるものでも大した味がないんですよ
蕎麦とラーメンと何がそんな微妙に違うんだけど
どっちも それほどすごい差がないんです
それでも蕎麦が好きと思っちゃうとどうなるんですか？やっぱり足が引っ張られてる
そこに自由がなくなってるでしょ
モーツァルトの音楽好きですよと言った途端
そこでパシッと自由が
いかなる概念も作用するんです
これは私のお母さんやと言う場合は
概念でしょ 言わなくたってもお母さんという概念があるでしょ
頭の中に そこで自由がなくなってるでしょ
だから一切概念を乗り越えたところは涅槃なんです
だから想像できない なぜならば想像は概念でやってますから
まあそういうことで 我々は心にこのすごい知恵の
知恵が入らないような鍵は
私は知ってるんだぞという鍵なんです
我々高慢ですけど 普通はね
知ってるんだぞと言っちゃうと
はい 知恵の世界にはガチンと鍵がかかっています
だからとことん愚か者になってしまいます
もともとみんなアホ 愚か者でもどうしたことないんです
特別に頭のいい人間わけでもないんです
でも人間は２種類です
自分が本当に知らないものばっかりこの世の中でもいいやという感じでいる人と
嫌になるんだと その人は1片も知恵が開発している
私はこれも知ってる これも知ってる
言ったらもう日々知恵が衰えている
これ何かエピソードあるはずなんだよな
どういうエピソードですかね
何？ スリの話  ん？ スリの話が聞きます
二人の  スリ？スリの話？ お金をスる人
うん  そういうことで 一応一つの
この偈の意味を終了いたしました
一応まあ 次にこの悟りの過程においても同じことで
私はここまで進んでる
ここまで進んでると思う人々はもう進まないんです
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は
特に自分がまだこれがある
まだこれがある まだこれがあるという風にね
そういうダメなところを見る道なんです
なかなかやらないんですね
まあ気分が良かった 落ち着きましたとか
なんてすごいかというね
その自慢するとね 成長しませんよ
まあそれは得たものは得たもので
気分は落ち着いたんだけど
まだこの野郎ダメじゃないかと
自分のことをね いろんなダメなところを見るんですよ
落ち着いていたつもりなのに
ちょっとしたことで混乱してたんだから何が俺だと
そういうふうに やっぱりこれをこの自分の未熟なところばかり見るんですよ
だからかなり勇気が必要ですよ
そうでなきゃ まあなんかもうもうあまりにも悲観的になっちゃって
落ち込んじゃってもうどうにもならんだからね
微妙ですからね だからもともとすごい精神的な勇気って
本当に知識人でなければできない世界なんですよ
知識人っていうのはもう知らないことばっかし気づいているいて,もうとんでもない暗い連中だからね
でも逆に暗くないんですよ
ヴィパッサナーもものすごい知識世界でのことだから
まあやったところじゃなくて
やらなかったところばっかし
やっぱりまだダメか まだ怒るんだ
まだ欲ばかり んじゃないかとか
また怠けちゃうんじゃないかとかね
昨日一生懸命考えて 今日はどうですか
自分がとかね それで情けないんだ
そういう風に自分のもう未熟
未熟なところ こればっかり
ばっかり ばっかり見て
やることいっぱいあるというね
そういう風に修行を進むと
確実に悟りまで行くんです
今ここまで達しているんだから
いかがでしょうか 次はと
次はないんです その人に
そこで待ちなさい 閻魔さんの呼びが来ますからと
それしかないんです まあその性格
まあできるだけ我々もね
そこら辺直そう直そうとしていますけど
でもあまりにも強くその性格がついていると
もう まあ待ってくださいということしか言わないんですね
だから中道の瞑想だから
あまりにもね 欠点ばっかり見て
自分というのはどうにもならん情けない人間やって悲観的になったら
これ極論であって正しくない
ここまで進んだから なかなか私はね
欠点の悪くあるもんですねとか
それまた極論でダメなんですね
そうではなくて もうちゃんと中道で見て中道で見るんだけど
まだまだ学ぶべきところに
いつでも有学だからね
学ぶべきところにいつでも強調するんです
どんな学生でも研究者でも学者でも同じやり方ですよ
何か試験合格したら あれって面白かった
こういうことを勉強すると
またあの本は触らないでしょうに
去年受験勉強にしても
この本もう一度勉強してやろうとかね
それでもダメでしょうに
一つの合格したら次のところに挑戦するでしょうに
そうするとまたわからない本ばっかり出てくるんだから
英語の試験にしても 一つ合格したら
じゃあ次に合格する受けるそうとなった
それでそのテキストのさっぱりわからなくない
今まで読めたのに それ次のテキストは読めない
わからなくて 単語わかっても意味がわからないとかね
日本ではちょっと何でも日本語訳するんだからね
まあ問題ないんだからね
英語ってすごい微妙な複雑な言語っていうことは気づかないんですね
だから勉強してもしても別に役に立たないのはすごいありがたいんだけど
普通は英語は英語でやりますからね
翻訳しながらやれないんです
そこでどんどん上に なんかいろんな作家の有名な作家のテキストとか
それセクションセクション読んでよく読めるで
読めるもので それ試験を買ったら合格までして
あーできそうだな 英語でって
じゃあ次の試験テキストある
開けてみたら全然わからなかった
1ページ私は 1ページは半分ぐらいなんとかいくんだけど
残り半分はいかない 次のページ開けてみたら
もう全然さっぱり いやね
これできるもんじゃないかと
それで自分があんたまだまだ英語わかってないってことに気づくんだからね
そこでそれなりにできたところで
まあシェイクスピアを直接読みなさいってことになっても
試験にもシェイクスピアの本 2冊あって
開けてみたら単純な英語で
微妙な古い英語出てくるだけで
それは単語いくつかしかないんだから
それはもうちょこっと
まあこれはこれで これでこれでとかね
ああ シェイクスピアってすごい簡単でね
またドラマでしょうし
読んでやるぞと ただ 先生たちがね
これ違いますと この単語の意味はね
現代で普通の普通の英語だからね
でも意味は違いますよ
これはもうかなり昔の英語やと覚えておきなさいと
だから意味違いますと
言ったところで ああ やっぱり注釈書を参考にしなくちゃいけないんだと
それでもう自慢気に読むんじゃなくて
まず注釈書と現代英語で書いてるものを読みながら
原文を参考にしながらと読みだしちゃったんです
そういうことだから やっぱり学校の世界でも学ぶ方法っていうのは
やっぱり知らないところに重点を置かなくちゃいけない
瞑想の場合でも もう学んでないところに重点を置いておいて
挑戦して挑戦していくんです
進んだところはもう終わったもんだからね
どうってことはないんです
例えば第1番段階に悟って
実体としての自我がないんだそうと発見しても
やっぱり自我がないんだ
やっぱりすごいことやってそこでウロウロしちゃうと
もうブッダから見怒られる
おるかお前はと 自我がないんだけど
怒るでしょうし 欲があるでしょうし
いい加減それで もう実体ないことは分かったんだけど
まだ自分が情けないんだと
だらしないんだと これがあってこれがあって
これがあって 何これ？ということで嫌になっちゃって
また修行するんです それと
またあの過去で経験したあの無我の境地
経験 それはないんです
自分の未熟なところにものすごく当たって当たっているんですから
このこれは仏道の大変大事なことなんです
愚かさに気づけということは
で まあどうしますか またもう一つそれで話もうほんまに終わる
この芸は もう一つやるかやらないかというね
で 判断してください